Slip on those Gauntlets of Submission and
get ready to tussle the Wonder Woman 1984
trailer is here, and boy, oh boy, it's bursting
at the seams with action and a whole lot of
heart.
Let's take a look at what this feast of a
trailer gave us after so many months of build-up.
Wonder Woman 1984 is set at an interesting
time in Diana Prince's on-screen history:
33 years before Justice League, which was
set in the then-present day of 2017, and 66
years after the original Wonder Woman, which
took place across various European countries
in the year 1918.
As the title tells us, the sequel takes Diana's
story to 1984, when she's living in America.
In the Wonder Woman 1984 trailer, framed pictures
on Diana's mantle imply that she's moved overseas
to connect with members of Steve Trevor's
family hoping to, in what small ways she can,
remember the man she loved who seemingly died
at the end of the first Wonder Woman film.
But was Diana's presumed contact with Steve's
family overt or covert?
Did she keep in touch with her other friends
like Etta, or Charlie, or Chief Napi?
By the '80s, all these people would likely
be long dead.
But Steve Trevor well, he's a different story.
Yes, Chris Pine really is back as Steve Trevor.
He's not dead, and, to quote director Patty
Jenkins, he's "not a gimmick" he's here to
really hang out in a future he couldn't possibly
imagine, decked out in windbreakers and fanny
packs.
"It's all art."
Steve stops in front of trash can.
"That's just a trash can."
"This is just a trash can — yeah, yeah,
yeah."
The trailer dances around exactly how Steve
comes back from the presumed dead, but the
footage does give a lot of credence to the
Wonder Woman 1984 rumors reported over the
last few months that there exists a supernaturally
powered artifact that brings Steve to the
current timeline.
Though Pine has previously admitted he doesn't
get a whole lot of action sequences in Wonder
Woman 1984, he seems to be a huge part of
the narrative overall considering he spends
a ton of time with Diana in the trailer.
It's sweet and fulfilling to see Diana and
Steve realize the romance they didn't quite
get to in Wonder Woman, but all of it is inherently
tinged with a sense of doom because we know
Steve didn't appear in Justice League and
Diana was mocked by that film's antagonist
over his death.
Whatever happens, let's hope Diana gets the
longer goodbye she deserves if Steve must
disappear into the ether of time once more.
As the Wonder Woman 1984 trailer shows, Diana
seems to still be working within the world
of art and antiquities, and she becomes acquainted
with an archaeologist named Barbara Ann Minerva.
Kristen Wiig portrays Barbara, who, over the
course of the film, will take on the superpowered
mantle of Cheetah.
The Wonder Woman 1984 trailer didn't provide
any shots of Barbara post-Cheetah transformation,
and instead focused on presenting her as a
new friend to Diana.
At the start of the footage, the two women
are seen chatting at a table, talking about
whether they've been in love.
"Have you ever been in love?"
"A long, long time ago."
"You?"
"So many times.
Yeah.
All the time."
"You?"
Barbara has a magnificent, punkish '80s energy
to her — she wears studded animal print
leather jackets, has big frizzy hair, and
rocks round nerdy glasses.
As an archeologist, she and Diana have a very
natural path to meeting through a shared industry,
and are seen attending what appears to be
the same slick parties with dignitaries in
what we assume to be Washington D.C., where
most major antiquities for the United States
are kept in the Smithsonian.
In the DC comics, Cheetah is a major antagonist
against Diana, so the Wonder Woman 1984 trailer
presenting them as new friends sets the stage
for a tragedy.
Gal Gadot [guh-DUT] also might've let something
slip at CCXP when she mentioned in passing
that Diana wants to save some of the antagonists
she confronts in the film.
Rumors have been floating around for a while
that Barbara will become Cheetah as a result
of slick businessman Maxwell Lord more on
him in a bit granting her wish to be like
Wonder Woman, whom she admires more than anyone
else.
According to the rumors, Barbara's new powers
will frighten Maxwell, who reaches out to
Diana for protection from Cheetah.
Speculation also has it that Maxwell's bargain
for these services is using a mystical artifact
in his possession to bring Steve Trevor back
to Diana the greatest wish to grant of all.
If this is true, Cheetah and Wonder Woman
are headed for a collision of circumstance,
and it would indeed be in Diana's nature to
pity the afflicted and want to help her.
Circling back to Maxwell Lord, he's the central
villain of Wonder Woman 1984, and The Mandalorian
actor Pedro Pascal portrays him.
Maxwell Lord in the DC Comics canon is a CEO
of some scientific mega-corporation a lá
Lex Luthor, but Maxwell Lord in Wonder Woman
1984 is "the king of infomercials," presented
as a continued nod to the particular gods
we served during that decade.
His ultimate desire and the plan to achieve
it isn't explicitly stated in the trailer.
Still, one of his many ominous lines in the
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer is:
"Think about finally having everything you
always wanted."
… which is no doubt a reflection of his
own ulterior motive.
Like every evil salesman, Maxwell is a master
manipulator, and will utilize this skill to
get exactly what he wants at any cost.
One of the best treats in the Wonder Woman
1984 trailer was saved for last: a brand-new,
flashy suit of golden armor with wings.
After watching Diana go toe-to-toe with an
actual, capital-g God in 2017's Wonder Woman
without needing heavy armor, we can only wonder
just what she's getting up to in Wonder Woman
1984 to need something so resplendent.
Comics refer to the shiny get-up as her Golden
Eagle armor, but they don't provide a whole
lot of clues or a special enemy it was used
for.
Historically speaking, Diana simply needs
it for conflicts in which she needs to be
a soldier, as opposed to the champion of love
she prefers to be.
That considered, there's a possibility that
the armor could be used as a remix of a comic
plot from 2016.
In it, Wonder Woman has a final confrontation
with Cheetah, but rather than showing up to
kill her, Wonder Woman takes a brutal onslaught
from her former friend.
Ultimately, she embraces Cheetah with love
and peace for two reasons: Cheetah is a villain
created by the abuses of others and isn't
inherently evil; and Diana always wants to
rehabilitate rather than kill.
A suit of armor would fit the bill for that
excellently, and make for a nice reversal
of the trope that heroes only need armor for
ruthless fights to the death.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.